foreign
the essence of philosophy is that a man
should so live that his happiness shall
depend as little as possible on external
things
people are not disturbed by things but
by the views they take of them
[Music]
a city is not adorned by external things
but by the virtue of those who dwell in
it
[Music]
he who exercises wisdom exercises
knowledge of God
[Music]
to accuse others of One's Own Misfortune
is a sign of lack of Education
to accuse oneself shows that one's
education has begun
to accuse neither oneself nor others
shows that one's education is complete
in every Affair consider what precedes
and what follows then take action
[Music]
those proficient praise no one blame no
one and accuse no one
difficulties reveal the character of men
[Music]
events happen as they do people behave
as they are Embrace what you get
neither call yourself a philosopher nor
talk among the unlearned about theorems
but act according to them
when anyone provokes you be assured that
it is your opinion that provokes you
lameness is an impediment of the leg not
of the will
be free from grief not through
insensibility like irrational animals
nor through want of thought like the
foolish
but like a man of virtue by having
reason as the consolation of grief
fortify yourself with contentment
this is an impregnable Fortress
it is better to do wrong seldom and to
own it than to do wrong often but never
admit it
foreign